the last aspect of the Trump
muslim-majority country immigration ban
I want to discuss is will it achieve the
supposed goal and I say suppose it
because we've already talked about how
its absolute in total a total PR stunt
optics will the majority Muslim
immigration ban achieve the supposed
goal of keeping America safe the answer
is no this becomes and already has
become a terrorist recruiting talking
point it is the number one terrorist
recruiting talking point right now the
US has banned Muslims or people from our
country or whatever join up let's go
attack them and I want to go further if
you believe as many Trump ians do and
this may be true I'm not denying that it
may be true that there are cells radical
jihadist cells in the US who may have
been born here as citizens of the US or
have long since legally come to the
United States if you believe that there
are these cells ready to be activated
this band does nothing than to provide
an impetus to activate those cells
sooner than later and jihadist groups
are already using this to their
advantage as a report this morning in
the Washington Post that a number of
jihadist groups are calling this a
victory there are comments on throw Isis
social media saying that this will make
it easier to get people to side with
extremists one post hailed Trump's ban
as the best caller or Donald Trump
himself as the best caller to Islam
several postings suggested the Trump was
fulfilling the predictions of Anwar
al-awlaki the american-born al Qaeda
leader this doesn't keep America safe
Pat I mean it largely reminds me two of
the drone strikes that we've been
committing to thinking that it's going
to keep us safe but really you're just
cropping the next generation of Paris
obvious and of course also hypocritical
as I mentioned earlier is that we didn't
even ban the country from which the 911
terrorist primarily came from Saudi
Arabian or even the secondary countries
and there's also a logistical issue here
that makes this even more obviously
optics and politics to appeal to the
lowest common denominator the
low-information Trump Ian Libya is
banned we issued like 1,500 visas to
Libya in 2015 we issued millions of
Jesus to China comparatively just not
not to bring China into this
unnecessarily but to give you a sense of
the number of visas that we issued to
some countries Saudi Arabia which is a
muslim-majority country notably missing
from the list received 100,000 visas in
2015 Iraq is on the list only 10,000
visas went to people from Iraq Yemen is
on the list only 3,500 visas went to
people from Yemen many of the countries
band Pat are also statistically almost
irrelevant yeah this is entirely about
optics and I think to anyone who thought
that Trump was not going to fall through
with his rhetoric on the campaign trail
yeah I mean they've been proven wrong
here yeah she did it it just makes
absolutely no sense and and does not
make America safer and lastly we have to
consider the retaliation aspect Iran
said on Saturday it's going to stop US
citizens from entering their country and
direct response here and I know some
people will say oh who cares who wants
to go to Iran anyway yeah I get that but
if it's Iran in this particular case
other countries could be added to the
list and even though it might not sound
like a place to vacation many of the
countries on this list are important in
terms of diplomacy and this could become
a really really big issue in 24 hours
the biggest sort of notable
accomplishment of this thing is that
Donald Trump single handedly made people
number one want to support yellow taxis
in New York City as they were boycotting
bringing people to JFK Airport we could
talk about whether that makes sense or
not but it's fascinating that people of
but all of a sudden they're like hey
let's support yellow cabs in New York
which are often hated by many New
Yorkers and also it prompted people to
show up at JFK Airport when they didn't
even have to which is also something
that you generally want to avoid a few
of in New York ever having to go to JFK
Airport because it is absolute chaos
last thought on this could these attempt
that the twenty percent tariff on Mexico
which I'll talk about the
muslim-majority country band etc could
these be Steve ban and Donald Trump
attempts to propose something crazy
initially so that then later they can
back off of it slightly and people turn
away and say well it's not as crazy as
what they started with for example
Muslim ban canceled visa
support people who were in the airport
and then later they sort of end up when
ago she ating back to okay if you
already have the visa you can come here
is that a green card you can come here
etc but any future immigration is going
to be banned there's an interesting
aspect to that where maybe this is
really extreme on purpose to end up
negotiating to something that will make
people say well it's not as crazy as
what we started with I guess I won't
worry about it anymore I think that's
kind of generous I don't know if they've
had the foresight to think that the
executive orders would have those kind
of long lasting implications yeah I mean
I think they're just kind of going
through with what they can feeling
around in the darkness Oh to speak yeah
and that's been something we heard of
that the legal the legal teams got this
like a half hour before it was signed or
something what a show we have for you
today i'm on twitter at d pakman send me
your thoughts